let's talk about political fundraising
we've been looking at polling but we
have not been looking at fundraising the
second quarter just ended the second
quarter is April May and June and we
have some very interesting new
fundraising data I do not yet have Joe
Biden's fundraising data for the second
quarter when I have it I will tell you
what it is but Donald Trump's
fundraising has exploded significantly
in Q2 assuming of course that the Trump
campaign is being honest in their
reporting Trump pulled in per Politico
more than 35 million dollars in the
second quarter
that is nearly double what Trump raised
in q1 and suggests Politico rights that
the indictments are helping with
fundraising and the article goes into
detail in q1 Trump raced just under 19
million dollars in Q2 Trump raised more
than 35 million dollars important to
note The Joint fundraising committee is
split between Trump's official campaign
and his leadership packs save America at
least in theory the save America Pac is
meant to raise money for people that
Trump endorses or supports
um the official did not break down how
much of that 35 million went to Trump
versus the PAC but the most recent
fundraising solicitations direct 90
percent of each donation to Trump's
campaign and 10 to the save America pack
the pack by the way also lately is
focusing spending on non-campaign
activity like paying for Trump Trump's
legal bills so there are a few different
things to talk about here first and
foremost the average donation was 34.20
we have people
who can only afford to give about 30
bucks
paying for a billionaires legal fees a
billionaire who has a private jet they
are sending money to a guy with a
private plane for his legal fees because
of all of the crimes he allegedly
committed and all they can really do is
30 bucks because statistically they
can't meet an unexpected 400 expense
that they might be presented with
that's insane that is insane and grift
after grift you know I hate to do this
sort of like uh Caveat Emptor a fool in
their money are soon parted we can't
have a nanny State protecting these
people like I I don't want to go in that
direction but after the grift of 2016
where Trump raised money money money
despite saying I don't really need any
money I'm rich enough to run on my own
with all of these promises that he
didn't meet
and then he ran again in 2020 saying I'm
making the same promises all over again
even though I didn't meet them in the
first campaign this time I will and
people donate and then Trump loses and
then Trump says Hey Now I need your
money in order to overturn elections and
do forensic audits where we're going to
look ballot by ballot for bamboo fibers
or barbecue sauce or or whatever the
case they were looking for and also for
filing lawsuits and then half of that 70
of that went to paying Trump's campaign
bills grift after grift after grift and
now he's doing it again and they're
still donating money for legal fees
um at this point I don't think there's
anyone who can protect these people and
probably we shouldn't even continue
trying I want to hear from you on that
question should these folks who continue
to donate money to the obvious grift
should we even care at this point or at
some point is it a matter of personal
responsibility like Republicans love to
say and they need to be parted with
their money if they are going to fall
for it again let me know what you think
we are going to keep an eye on the Biden
fundraising numbers also as far as
fundraising this is a very interesting
report from axios from yesterday
called Democrats amass early War chest
for brutal 2024 Senate map uh the 2024
Senate map is not a great map for
Democrats remember that with a hundred
senators in the Senate uh every two
years a third of them are up for
re-election the terms are six years long
but these are sort of overlapping
classes in the Senate the third of the
Senate that happens to be up for
reelection in 2024 is not particularly
good for Democrats what is very
interesting is that a number of uh a
number of prominent Democrats are doing
really well in terms of fundraising
Senator Bob Casey in Pennsylvania has
raised more than four million dollars
that's his best fundraising quarter ever
senator Tammy Baldwin from Wisconsin
first openly LGBT woman in the Senate
raised over three million dollars that
is also a record high Adam Schiff broke
the record for second quarter Senate
fundraising remember he's a member of
Congress but he's running for Dianne
Feinstein's seat which he will be
vacating these are stunning stunning
stunning numbers but there are many
Republicans who are doing well as well
in Nevada retired U.S army Captain Sam
Brown uh is likely to launch a senate uh
campaign
against the Democrat there and that
potentially is going to uh do well in
terms of uh fundraising there are
Republicans who have the potential with
major Republican Senate campaign support
to also do well but the encouraging sign
here is
it
right now
if we want a proxy to enthusiasm for
2024 we would look at fundraising I
don't have the Biden Q2 numbers but I do
have some Senate Q2 numbers and they
look very good particularly considering
that it's July of the year before the
election hope is not lost and the Senate
could end up being okay in 2024 that's
where we'll leave it we'll take a quick
break after this I am going to talk
about threads the new Twitter competitor
we're going to talk about so many
different things glad you're with us
today
are you tired of getting crushed in the
market or the volatility there is some
good news which is that treasury yields
are surging you can now get a whopping
five percent yield on treasury bills
that is higher than any high yield
savings account that I have seen but
buying U.S treasuries can be a
complicated process at least it used to
be that's where our sponsor public.com
comes in with public you can buy
treasury bills in seconds right from
your phone couldn't be easier plus
public will even automatically roll over
your Investments at maturity so you have
one less thing to think about take
another thing off your plate treasury
bills are government-backed securities
considered one of the safest Investments
out there and when you buy them through
public they are securely stored at the
Bank of New York Mellon which is the
largest custodian Bank in the world no
minimum hold periods no settlement
delays you have full access to your
funds whenever you need them put your
cash to work earn that five percent
yield by going to public.com Pacman
don't miss the opportunity the link is
down below